Jeff Epstein, thank you so much
for joining us on 20 Minute Leaders.
It's wonderful to be here.
Thank you for having me.
Okay. So if I started to give
a brief bio about you,
I wouldn't be able to ask you any questions
because 20 minutes would be over.
But just for context.
Previous CFO of Oracle,
but not just any CFO,
because you've also been on the boards
of the coolest companies.
Currently on Twilio and Shutterstock.
Incredible companies.
But you're on the board
of Booking Holdings.
And you joined, you said
when it was a billion dollars in revenues
growing up to 80?
Billion dollars in market value,
growing to 80 billion.
Wow. Okay.
So, billion dollars in market value
going up to 80 billion.
But you're also on the board of
Kaiser Permanente?
Kaiser Permanente is a large
non-profit health care organization
that provides both healthcare,
hospitals and health insurance
for 12 million people,
mostly in California and
the West Coast.
Unbelievable. And you mentioned
230,000 employees.
Right.
Unbelievable. So, you're
sitting on these boards.
So I'm gonna have to at some point
understand how do you even juggle
all of these different positions
and how do you then take the skills
from the CFO at Oracle and now at Apex,
which hopefully
we'll be able to get to as well.
But Jeff, how do you do it all?
It's a serious question.
I mean when I think of who I want,
the level that I wanna get to
one day and have these
incredible experiences,
you're the persona right now.
Thank you very much.
Well, I spent 25 years working
full time as a chief financial officer
where every day you have people
that report to you and you have a boss
and a board and quarterly earnings.
And that was a lot of responsibility.
Now that I'm retired from full time work,
I serve on these boards but you go to a board meeting -
Retired. Okay.
I just wanna put the word
retired in front of everything
that I just said. Okay.
So the difference between
being a board member is usually
you go to the board meeting,
you ask a lot of questions.
You say,
"Boy, sounds like you've got a lot of problems.
I'll see you at next board meeting."
And management are the people that
have to fix the problems
we just talk about them.
So, there is a lot of governance responsibility,
and if occasionally if you have to change
the CEO or things like that.
There's a lot of work
but there are certain companies
like Wells Fargo,
and over the last few years,
they've had, there were PG&E going through bankruptcy.
They have a very intense experience,
but if the company is doing well,
it's a lot easier to be a board member
than to the day to day
responsibility of being executive.
Of course. Of course.
And of course -
Very rewarding as well
because my job is to ask questions.
And so, I love learning.
I love asking questions,
and over the year, after 40 years,
you've asked a lot of questions,
you get to learn a lot.
It reminds me of the nice story
of when you go to the doctor
and something is hurting in your knee
and the doctor hits your knee and says,
"Okay now five hundred dollars, please."
And you ask,
"What? You just hit the knee?"
And he said,
"No, no, no. I've been studying
for 40 years how to hit your knee."
So, it sounds like the questions
that you're asking now,
they're not just any questions,
they're questions with dozens of years
and a wealth of experience
that you bring with you.
Right. Exactly.
I'll give you an example of a board meeting
and I've been trying to talk
to some of my CEOs about this.
Many of the people on this call might have
actually participated in a board meeting.
And in my mind, there's sort
of three parts to a board meeting.
There's the compliance part,
the audit committee report,
compensation committee,
things like that,
which in a private company
is very short.
In a public company
it's there's some amount of time.
And then the remainder of the time
often is the management telling the board
what they've been doing.
Reporting on what's going on.
Here's our
product strategy
Here's our sales and marketing strategy.
Here's our forecast.
I call that the show and tell part.
And then there's another
part of the meeting,
the third part, which is
here are decisions
we're thinking about,
but we haven't made them yet,
and we'd like to tell you
We have three choices
and here's the pros and cons
of each choice.
We recommend option A.
We're planning on doing option A.
But what do you think?
And maybe your questions
and your guidance will change our mind.
So, should we grow faster
and burn more money,
lose more money,
or should we grow slower and make more money?
Right.
We have one product just in the US.
Should we add a second product in the US,
or should we take our first product
and expand to the UK?
Those kinds of decisions.
So, I personally find the decisions we have
not yet made to be a much more valuable
board meeting as opposed
to the show and tell.
And the show and tell, in my view,
can be done in writing.
Put everything, create this big presentation,
send it out to the board
a week in advance.
We'll read it all.
We'll ask questions
if we don't understand it,
but to spend most of the board time
just telling us what's in the written material
is to me not taking full advantage of the board.
So that's an example of the kind
of thing that I've learned over the years,
which 20 years ago,
I probably didn't understand.
Now I try to nudge my CEOs
in that direction.
How would you describe your relationship
with your CEOs as a board member?
And you have quite a few CEOs
that you have to be in touch with.
Is this a friendly relationship?
Is this more of a boss-employee relationship?
What's the intimacy like over there?
Well, it depends.
If I work for the venture capital partners
or private equity partners,
they essentially,
they are appointed by their firm
or the private equity firm
Maybe they hire the CEO.
In the companies that I'm involved in,
personally because I'm always an independent,
the CEO meets me and personally
wants, recruits me to the board.
So, the CEO essentially
hired me to be a board member.
And essentially,
the CEO can fire me if they decide
they don't like me on the board.
It's never happened, but they could.
And so, my role is to help
make the CEO as effective
as he or she could be.
And so, it's by asking questions,
by telling stories and anecdotes.
So, one way to think about it is,
My dogs in the background
I don't know if you can hear it sorry -
I love it. It just adds. It adds.
So, Mark Twain said that
history doesn't repeat itself,
but it does rhyme.
And so, if I've been involved
in a company before
that had a similar problem,
I might tell the story.
Here's what the situation was.
It sounds similar.
Here's what they did.
Here's what happened.
But that doesn't mean
you should do the same thing
because every situation's different.
Right.
And so can we stop for a minute
I'm gonna see if I could get the dogs quiet.
No problem.
You'll have to edit that part out.
No worries at all.
Okay
That's what's nice about this
spontaneousness of this is
that these things just add
because it creates much more
of I think of an intimacy
with my friends from Tel Aviv
and Stanford who are viewing this
because it's not edited.
There's no agenda
to make it look perfect.
It's as if we're having coffee
and we're just sharing
with them our coffee.
Okay. Right.
So, you were telling me about Mark Twain.
Yeah. So, Mark Twain said
history doesn't repeat itself,
but it does rhyme.
And so my interpretation of that is
if I'm at a board meeting
and something comes up with the company
and there's a challenge or a problem,
I'll say: Well, in two or three other
situations, I had a similar
type of situation.
Here's what the situation was.
Here's what the company did.
It worked or it didn't work.
That doesn't mean that you, the CEO,
should do the same thing
because your situation is gonna be
somewhat different.
But if you never had any similar experience,
you're flying blind
whereas if you have the benefit of mine
or other people's experience,
you can triangulate and piece together
the pieces of the puzzle and say,
"Well, I think this is relevant."
And then you make up your own mind.
So, I basically work as a board member,
not by telling people what to do,
but by asking questions
and by telling stories.
I think that's incredible.
And I haven't gotten to that position
and I very much hope to one day
be able to be a CEO
where you're on the board of.
So wait for that request one day.
But it sounds to me
that a lot of these things
you can look up online
and read case studies
from business schools
and understand that
how you get to point B from point A.
But it sounds like
a lot of the added benefit
that you would bring to the table
is not just A and then B,
but it's the whole process
and the whole, and the relationships
and the intricacies that
and the complexity that goes into it.
So, you know all the details
of the whole process
and not just the outcome, right.
Yeah it's not only the details,
it's also the emotional impact
of having lived through it.
Right.
So, you've probably heard the phrase,
"Raise money when you can,
not when you need it"
And if you hear that, you say,
"Okay well that makes sense.
That's logical."
But I've actually lived through it
and I'll tell you that story.
I was the CFO of DoubleClick
during the Internet boom.
And our stock went from,
we went public
at $250 million at market value,
and we were up to $11 billion.
So, we were trading at 22 times revenue,
a huge price.
We're still losing money.
We're growing fast.
And we were the leading Internet
advertising technology company.
But by any measure,
the company was fully valued.
I mean, we clearly weren't undervalued.
And so we decided to raise money.
And we did a follow-on offering
and we were in the market
raising $700 million.
It's a public company.
And we had a roadshow
which started Monday morning.
We were at a price Thursday night.
And on Wednesday at lunch,
I'm presenting to investors
at a luncheon meeting
and I get a call from my office.
The message said, "Call NASDAQ".
So, I call NASDAQ and they say,
"You know, we have a problem."
And I go, "Really? What's the problem?"
And he said, "Well, we have a lot of sell orders."
And I said, "Really? Well how many?"
And he says, "Well, we have so many sell orders
and no buying interest
that we're stopping
trading in your stock."
And so, for the rest
of that Wednesday afternoon,
our stock ... trade.
And what had happened was
there was an article in USA Today
that morning about how DoubleClick
was violating people's privacy.
And that just spooked investors.
They didn't know what to think about it.
So, we sit with our investment bankers
Wednesday night and we say
"What's gonna happen?"
And they predict accurately
that the stock's gonna open up
tomorrow morning, down 20%.
So, a nine billion dollar valuation.
And the question is,
should we just pull the offering
or should we go ahead with the offering
at the 20% lower valuation?
And my feeling was the price
that it was yesterday is irrelevant.
The question is, is nine billion a fair price
Yes or no.
And for a company with
500 million in revenue losing money,
I thought that was a very,
still a very good valuation.
And even though we had
200 million in cash,
we didn't need the money.
I thought it was just a sensible thing
to raise money when you can.
So, I recommended and then
we went ahead and raised money.
And then of course, the whole market
Internet market collapsed.
The advertising market collapsed.
Our revenue over the next two years
dropped by 50% from
500 million to 250 million.
But we had 700 million in cash.
So, we had a very strong balance sheet.
So, it's one thing to say it,
it's another to live through it.
That's unbelievable.
So, and we all have,
if you're old enough,
you'll all have stories like that.
That's just unbelievable.
And of course,
throughout this whole thing,
I gently forgot to mention that
that you are teaching
one of the most popular courses
at Stanford,
which I very much hope
to take myself one day.
Hopefully this upcoming winter.
And you're also an operating partner
at Bessemer,
one of the world's leading
venture capital firm.
What do you do there?
What does that even mean
an operational partner?
Well I'll talk about that,
but I do want to talk
about the class, too.
Yes.
An operating partner means
I'm not an investing partner.
So I don't make any decisions
to invest customers money.
I can invest my own money,
side by side with Bessemer.
And since I was a career CFO
what I've done is
I've created a CFO advisory board
among Bessemer's portfolio company CFOs.
So, we have 100 portfolio company CFOs
And in any company,
there might be 100 or 200 or 300 employees,
that CFO probably has no one else
in the company to talk to about
a finance related issue.
Right.
But across the portfolio,
there's a hundred people to talk to.
So we meet, pre-covid times, we meet in person
once a quarter.
Now we're meeting online.
We have an online platform where people
are asking each other questions
a couple times a week.
There's a big database of questions
over the last seven years.
So, it's a very rich valuable resource
of a peer group
among our portfolio companies.
And so I do that with the CFOs.
And then the CEOs
I help them in business or finance
or capital raising questions
or operation questions as well.
Wow.
But about the class,
what the Lean LaunchPad class is
It's in the winter quarter.
It's Engineering 245
in the Graduate School of Engineering
but business students typically
are half the class.
And it's teams of four or five students
with a startup idea.
And in 10 weeks they're required
to interview 100 potential customers.
Wow.
Build multiple prototypes,
have run many experiments,
and with any luck,
they generate their first revenue
by the tenth week.
And we've had now,
I guess this will be my eighth year teaching.
So, we've had quite a 100 teams or so,
graduate from the class.
And we've had maybe 15 teams
actually form companies and get funding
and some of them are doing quite well -
Wow. That's huge.
... revenues
and some very exciting companies.
One of them is fresh technologies,
which is AI for grocery ordering.
One is Zoom
which is Uber for children
or for schools type of system.
One of them is Nova, which is financial.
It's getting credit for ... immigrants
who might otherwise
find it hard to get credit.
So, a lot of really interesting
ideas and it's terrific.
I just love working with these
incredibly talented students.
And it's a great experience
for the students to get
as close to running a business
while you're still, without dropping out.
So it's a ...
experiential class.
I just get inspired by you.
Again in the first few minutes
you mentioned that you're retired,
and I think it just speaks to your passion
to everything that you're doing,
that you're considering yourself retired,
yet you do more than
people do in a lifetime.
To me, I mean, that's really the inspiration.
You know all the tips and tricks
they're amazing.
Very insightful.
But the fact that at the end
I get to speak to somebody who's
calling themselves retired,
yet they're doing extraordinary things.
I mean almost everything
that you're doing here
is world class level that
any amazing entrepreneur
would wish they could do.
To me, that's inspiring
and that's definitely
one of my goals in life
to be able to say that I'm retired
yet work as much as you do.
Jeff, I have to ask, CFO Oracle,
everybody knows Oracle
and the incredible things
that this company has done.
You've seen it also earlier on.
What does even a CFO do?
I don't get to speak to many
CFOs in my daily life.
Well, of course, the CFO at any size
company does is responsible for
the same functions.
Accounting, treasury
risk, capital raising,
financial planning and forecasting.
The difference is, is that
when I was the CFO of DoubleClick years ago,
I started out we had 180 people
and I probably did 25% of the work myself.
I would run the Excel models myself.
And then I ... the investor presentation myself.
And then I delegate 75% of the time.
You know you start off in your career
you do 100% yourself.
You have no one to delegate to.
Right.
At that time I was a manager.
I had a team.
Initially I had a team of maybe 10 people.
It grew to, probably at the peak there,
I would say maybe
a 100 people in finance
out of two thousand,
typically 5% of the head counts in finance.
But at Oracle,
I did virtually zero percent personally
and delegated 100%.
So, if I had written the
investor relations presentation myself,
the head of investor relations
would have said,
"You know why am I here?"
So, even if I have ideas
about investor relations,
the best way to do is to sit down with
the head of investor relations and say,
"You know here are some of my ideas,
but, you know, you go off and do it
and then I'll give you some guidance."
But fundamentally,
it's a leadership role as opposed to,
and it's a decision making role
as opposed to a doing
role so it changes quite a bit.
Oracle is an incredibly
well-run organization
and has been for decades.
And 40% profit margins.
And just extremely good
at what it does.
And how do you go through that transition?
I mean, yourself going and
having to see a company
through its early stages
to its more advanced stages.
How do you even get yourself to understand
because it's different orders
of magnitude for the problems, right?
We're back.
Wonderful.
I might have, I don't know it's my internet connection
Sorry about that
No worries.
What I was asking, though,
which was I think it's very interesting.
I mean, you've grown as a CFO
from early stage startups,
in terms of annual revenues,
all the way up to the billions.
It can't be the same mindset
and the same day to day
responsibilities and thinking.
You have to be transitioning yourself.
What is that like transitioning from
millions to billions?
Well, I did it over 25 years.
It wasn't overnight.
Still sounds very fast.
That is a big difference.
And between DoubleClick and Oracle,
I was the CFO of a big group at Nielsen,
the television ratings
and the Internet ratings company.
So, they were a global company
with many thousands of employees.
So, I had that exposure to large companies.
One difference that Larry Ellison, years ago,
the founder and chairman of Oracle.
Oracle started with a country structure,
grew very fast in the early days,
and they had Oracle US,
Oracle UK,
Oracle Japan.
And one day around,
I'd say 20 years ago, he said,
"We are a big company now,
but we're operating like
seventy five small companies.
And what we should do is centralize
and to take advantage of ... scale"
And so over the course of about two years,
they went from a 75 different
country structure
to one global structure.
So, each country had its own CEO
and its own CFO.
And then when it was all over,
there was no other CEOs,
no other CFOs.
I was the only person in Oracle
with the title of CFO.
There was only global controller,
one head of marketing.
Things like that.
And there are tradeoffs.
It can be centralized or decentralized.
But Oracle was
an example of an extreme case
of very effective
and efficient centralization.
In contrast, Booking Holdings grew
through acquisition
and we own booking.com,
Priceline, Kayak, Open Table,
and other companies
and each of those businesses
had its own,
not only its own CEO and CFO,
but had its own complete business.
There was almost no shared resources.
And it also ran extremely well
as a very decentralized
entrepreneurial organization.
So there's no right answer.
But I think whichever strategy you have
you want to execute it well.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
Jeff, I can't believe
our time is almost up.
It's so sad every time.
You know, give me
one or two earned secrets,
true earned secrets
that you would give me
a young entrepreneur,
just starting my journey.
Hopefully going to try to make an impact
and a dent on the world in a positive way.
What are really extraordinary things
that I should be keeping in mind
over the next decade
as I pursue this dream?
Well let me answer that in two ways.
For entrepreneurs, if you're starting
a company from scratch,
what we teach in this class is
the first step is to get
to product market fit.
And so, what you wanted my advice
for most companies, software companies,
is to try to create
the smallest possible product
with the smallest ever customers
who love you a lot.
And Paul Graham
...
puts it this way.
He said "You'd rather have 10 customers
who love you,
than a million customers
who like you"
And the logic is,
if you've created a product
that 10 customers love,
I'm pretty confident
you could find an 11th
and then you can find a 12th.
But if you have a lot of customers
who just like you, you know
tomorrow they're gonna go on
and like something else.
Right.
So you wanna start a small, and
if you think about
Facebook started just at Harvard
and within two weeks,
he had 90% of all Harvard students
loving Facebook.
And Airbnb started with literally
renting an airbed in someone's apartment.
So they started with a very small product
view and a very small number of customers,
but they built huge companies.
And so, I think you can't build
a jet engine company that way,
but for many businesses you can.
That's on the entrepreneur side.
If you're an employee,
my favorite sort of tactic is,
if when you're interviewing for a job,
you're gonna have a boss and ask your boss,
tell your boss this, say,
"Listen, let's pretend you hire me.
Let's imagine you hire me.
And a year from now you're sitting
giving me my performance review."
And you say,
"Boy, I made a great decision Jeff, hiring you,
for the following three
because you've accomplished
the following three things."
What are those three things?
What it does is
it forces your hiring manager
to crystallize what his
or her expectations are of you.
And then if you know exactly what
the expectations are,
then you can exceed them.
Can I reverse that
and use that as the hiring manager
as a tactic to really align expectations
properly and sort of give my ideal
performance review ahead of time
and then have them try to match it
throughout the year?
Yeah, I think that's a great
a second application. And then a third application is -
I love it.
when you start a new job
and you haven't already
had that conversation, have that conversation with your boss
the first week of your job
because ... a good leader will do that anyway.
But many managers and leaders
aren't experienced
and just don't know that tactic.
And then you can go for a long time
thinking you're doing
what you should be doing
and realizing that you're not necessarily
focused on the top goals.
I imagine that grows in a few
orders of magnitude in tech
when a lot of leaders
are not necessarily leaders,
but they are more tech experts
who've grown to be team leaders
organically through their organization.
Yeah. A similar example,
I focused there on three things,
but an even more powerful technique
is to focus on one thing.
So I sat at a dinner party once
next to George Roberts of KKR,
Kohlberg Kravis Roberts,
and we were talking about
the problems of education in America.
And he said, "You know, Jeff,
if you could do one thing to improve
education in America, what would be?"
And I had thought a lot about education,
but I actually never thought of that particular
If I only could do one thing,
what's the one most important thing?
And I realize that's actually
the best question to ask
many people in many circumstances.
Whatever your basement situation,
just say, "If you could do one thing,
what's the one most important
thing you could do?"
It's incredibly powerful.
I love it. I just love it.
Jeff, before we leave,
I have to ask you a question
that I ask every person on the show,
and I'm especially curious to hear your answer.
I'd love to hear three words
that you would use to describe yourself,
or if I were to ask any of the CEOs
that you've worked with,
whether they're at Shutterstock or
Booking or Kaiser,
what would they think of
when they think of Jeff Epstein?
Curious.
Analytical.
Helpful.
I love it.
Jeff, thank you so much for the inspiration.
Thank you for the time.
I can't even imagine how you're juggling
everything that you're doing
yet you're still giving me these 20 minutes.
And so thank you for your generosity.
I'll add that as the fourth word.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Great Michael, thank you very much.
And I'll see you in class in the winter.
Well, I'm sorry to say,
you actually have to apply to the class
and get accepted.
So ... application.
I'm just putting in the hint,
but I'll definitely apply.
Sounds good.
I'm planting the seeds.
Okay.
Take care. Bye bye.
Bye.